I went to summer camp because I wanted
to see if I could make a friend because
I'm really bad at making friends and I
don't know how people do it as an adult
called camp no counselors and it's when
about 200 grown-ups meet up to go to
summer camp
so we left downtown Toronto at about
five o'clock and they served us beers on
the bus the chartered bus to camp and
then when you get off they give you what
they say is your first friendship
bracelet a record okay so this is your
first furniture placement is very
adorable one of the big things that
happens at camp from counselors is
something called color war it's a relay
basically so the first part of color war
is are just a bunch of activities and
whoever wins those activities they get a
head start for what is called the Apache
relay whatever team wins the Apache
relay wins like the weekend my phone was
not gonna my hand four or five times
it's a frat party
hey sort of ended up falling into their
old social rules really quickly
and the atmosphere definitely had this
sense of sexual malice in it which is
something that I ended up covering in my
article long written committee I had a
lot of people telling you throughout the
weekend that it seemed like I wasn't
having any fun but parts of it were
really fun like it's fun to go to this
weird place in the middle of nowhere
where you don't really have any cell
phone reception and have an organization
take care of your meals and your drinks
and your fun
there's something really pure and
beautiful about that experience everyone
was just have a fun and they were having
a really particular kind of nostalgic
warm safe fun and it's our [ __ ] on that
I made 3 Facebook friends when I got
back which I thought was pretty good I
went to summer camp because I wanted to
see if I could make a friend because I'm
really bad at making friends that's the
thing that comes with that is a kind of
a dark side of what happens when adults
are sort of left without supervision in
the woods with beer
Wow